actualizamos la información económica de
nuestro programa directo américa
nuevamente le doy la bienvenida a
nuestro periodista de economía o
resultado hoy vamos a analizar las
cifras del empleo a nivel global buenas
o malas noticias
bueno malas noticias sobre todo porque
la incertidumbre que está generando la
pandemia del coronavirus con el brote de
nuevas variantes como un micrón está
ocasionando más pérdidas de los empleos
en 2022 raúl habrá unos 52 millones de
puestos de trabajo menos en comparación
con los niveles anteriores a la pandemia
según la organización
internacional del trabajo esto es el
doble de su estimación anterior de junio
de 2021 este año el número de horas
trabajadas será un 2% menos que antes de
la pandemia producto de la crisis
sanitaria el informe de la oit es sobre
las perspectivas sociales y el empleo
para 2022 que fue publicado hoy indica
que el desempleo mundial se mantendrá
por encima de los niveles anteriores al
coronavirus al menos hasta 2023
actualmente hay 207 millones de personas
desempleadas en el mundo frente a 186
millones en 2019
de recuperación del empleo son
divergentes con los indicios más
alentadores en europa y norteamérica y
los más negativos en latinoamérica y el
caribe y el sudeste asiático mientras
que por países aquellos altos de altos
ingresos saldrán de la crisis un poco
más rápido que aquellos de ingresos
medios y bajos según la organización
bueno jorge cambiamos ahora información
vamos hasta china donde el gobierno de
esa país presentó los datos de su
crecimiento económico
bueno el producto interno bruto en china
creció 8,1 por ciento esto según el el
banco de estadísticas que dio el informe
el día de hoy el gobierno recortó
también su tasa de interés por primera
vez en casi dos años para impulsar esa
economía que ha perdido fuerza debido a
una caída inmobiliaria ya lo protege el
coronavirus mientras la inflación es la
mayor preocupación para los banqueros
centrales en europa y eeuu parece que
los responsables políticos en china
apuestan por el crecimiento con el
recorte de los tipos de interés el año
pasado beijing aprovechó la demanda
exterior para intentar reajustar un poco
su economía primero frenó el crecimiento
a las grandes tecnológicas y redujo el
financiamiento a las inmobiliarias tras
la caída de ever en el sector
inmobiliario en china representa que
hace un tercio del producto interno
bruto y se encuentra en una depresión
cada vez más profunda y hay grandes
actores de ese sector que están al borde
del colapso pero china tiene varios
retos por superar para tomar el
liderazgo económico mundial entre ellos
sortearlas con todos los constantes
proteste la variante o micro en que lo
afecta y la caída en la venta de las
propiedades que se redujo la inversión
en la vivienda jorge vamos ahora a
hablar de las empresas unicornio y la
participación femenina en ellas cómo
está esa participación jorge bueno
bastante baja según los datos y los
estudios que hacen las empresas primero
es importante aclarar de qué se trata
cuando hablamos de un unicornio son
empresas privadas con un valor superior
a mil millones de dólares y que son
consideradas un boom que está siendo
impulsado por internet y por supuesto
por la pandemia pero un recuento
realizado por américaeconomía revela que
del total de unicornios de américa
latina que son alrededor de unos 40
solamente dos de ellos cuentan con
mujeres en su equipo fundador estos
unicornios son no van el banco digital
brasileño
la plataforma mexicana de compra y venta
de vehículos usados aunque la baja
representación femenina en los equipos
fundadores de unicornios no dicta la
realidad del ecosistema de
emprendimiento en la región de américa
latina del total de emprendimiento es un
24% en etapas tempranas pertenece a
mujeres según el monitor de
emprendimiento global pero uno de los
principales retos para las emprendedoras
es el acceso al financiamiento la
consultora global gender smart afirma
que existen 93 mil millones de dólares
en brecha de acceso a financiamiento
para las mujeres en la región
el estudio raúl indica que las startup
lideradas por mujeres levantaron
alrededor de 500 mil dólares en capital
mientras que su par masculino levantó en
alrededor 12 millones de dólares del
total de los emprendimientos femeninos
que han cerrado el 73 por ciento se debe
a la falta de financiamiento el dato
crece a nivel global en 2019 sobre el 28
por ciento de la inversión en 21 capital
se dirigió que se dirigía a las startup
que fueron fundadas por mujeres
ahora vamos a hablar de los indicadores
en asia y en europa
así es en asia los movimientos de
mercados bursátiles fueron escasos y los
datos económicos de china fueron mixtos
en europa las acciones subieron
ligeramente en las primeras operaciones
del lunes ya que los impresores se
centraron en las ganancias de las
empresas y cuánto le costó al serbio
novak djokovic su decisión de no
vacunarse mejor podría ser considerada
la vacuna más cara del mundo 2,1
millones de dólares costó la postura
anti vacunas de djokovic en posible paga
así como la oportunidad de entrar en la
historia del tenis mundial
puedes jorge gracias entonces por toda
la información económica nos vemos
mañana con más economía aquí en directo
américa y vamos ahora a repasar los
deportes con bucles
[Música]